this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
so i guess the two things i wanted to
discuss what the idea of the a city um
and
the idea
or that a city has
a kind of
intelligence or consciousness
and and that is the first kind of thing
i want to discuss and the second thing i
want to discuss is the nature of church
and
how that relates to
i guess our own spiritual journey i
think those two things are the things
that stand out for me personally um
listening to a lot of your youtube
material and those are the two like
interesting ideas to me like the idea of
a city as a
something
maybe conscious
and the idea that we can't kind of go it
alone in this life and
the kind of individualistic
like attempt to do that um has a limit
and
the community and the place of kind of
community in that in that journey
um
so i guess i guess
the main thing with the city is
you've said before that like um a city
is something we can pray to that we
that we can communicate with in a way
that's analogous to a person so i can
ask my friend the question and that
friend can choose to respond to that
question or not and but that's a kind of
uh prayer there or entreaty to my friend
like oh what do you think of this or
like that and in a similar way i can do
that
in a city
or a or a
something that's not as obviously a
person as my friend
in the sense that
they don't have a physical fleshy body a
city doesn't necessarily have that
so i guess
i'm trying to
think of how to formulate the question
um
maybe i can i can help you if you want
because i i understand the difference
you are i understand um
how it's difficult to think about it
that way
um so the first thing maybe to the first
thing to understand is that a city
definitely has a body
right it it it does have a
fleshy
physical
body okay it's just that it's not as
it's not it's not a body that we can
perceive at a glance the way that we
perceive a person at a glance right so
encounter person
there he is like he's contained in space
i can i can
you know i can go around them you know
the city is also like that but just
bigger it's just it's just bigger and
the space between the parts let's say
are bigger than the space between your
parts but you also have space between
your parts too right there's there's
massive amounts of space between your
molecules and between your different
parts it's just that at the at the human
level we don't necessarily interact with
them that's that's the first thing
that's important now the second thing
that's important to really understand
is that
all the things you encounter of the city
are always parts
of the city
and so they don't contain
the intelligence of the city they only
manifest it at their level
that's really important because we're
not which is all we can ever encounter
so we can is that as me
in bristol for example i can only
encounter the expressions
of the identity of bristol in its
particular
ways in which that participates in that
my story is that we were saying
exactly but not only not only that but
it's actually similar to even the way
you encounter a person
because when you encounter a person you
you're encountering their
their body
and you're encountering the sounds that
they make or the
you have all these experiences and then
behind that you can perceive
the intelligence but the intelligence is
is not
limited to the
the the fleshy stuff and the stuff i
hear right and so it's that's the that's
what's that's why sometimes when people
say when i say something like uh intel
like it's a a city
has being if the city has intelligence
then then people for some reason they're
still there and they have to exist
within the mater this weird material
world where the intelligence behind it
so
um so you can even imagine yourself like
even not only even your physical parts
but let's say even your mental parts
like your mental parts
are multiple
for different situations but they all
embody something like your spirit which
is completely
invisible and beyond the parts
so if i ask you if i um ask you to show
me how to cook
right or if i ask you to um
i don't know like i ask you a deeply
personal questions it's not the same
part of you that will engage me there'll
be different parts of you that will
engage me depending on your prayer
exactly depending on your prayer and so
you could imagine that like let's say
your
your spirit
will send emissaries
and those emissaries will will manifest
different aspects of you
depending on what is needed so if i come
at you with a knife
then you're not going to answer me with
the same emissary as if i if i come to
you with flowers right it's going to be
a different you're going to send a
different part of you
and so you can understand that the city
is the same where
you know you
you write like if you need something
you know let's say you there's a pothole
in your street
it's right in so and so now you want to
get rid of the pothole so you you
obviously won't write
to the the to like let's say the uh
the people that take care of the of the
parks let's say you'll write to the
people that take care of this of this
treaty so you'll write to the
the the
to the person at the city garage or
whatever whatever how it's structured in
your city and then you'll write them and
you'll ask them to
to come fix your pothole right and so
those people they're bound by the rules
of the city
but they're not acting just as joe and
jane
because they suppo they're supposed to
act according to the budget according to
the general projects according to the
the way in which these
these roads are built so they're
supposed to embody
the will of the city
so it strikes me as well
that
like there's an interesting connection
between
human beings as conscious
and
the city so when you say the city has a
body
one of the ways to think about that is
that like every member
every uh human member that makes it up
is comprises that body and so
i guess what i another question that
comes to mind is like
is it
so like i recognize there is a kind of
consciousness and intelligence to the
city
is that consciousness or intelligent
intelligence kind of in
our image if you if you know what i'm
saying like in the sense of
the words consciousness and intelligence
uh
personally i can only really have a
sense of what that means in terms of
like
this living life like the phenomenology
like my
uh experience i guess
and the
and i guess there's theological
traditions that talk about the the the
nature of the human soul
and or the human person and so
and and like
humans kind of have to establish cities
like a city couldn't be intelligent
without
human intelligence
uh
is kind of what it seems to me
and
if that's so are they
there's a way in which we could think
that that therefore we're kind of
projecting a kind of
i have a kind of consciousness and
therefore i recognize something similar
in the city but i don't want to go that
far because i do hear what you're saying
like there is a genuine kind of autonomy
kind of coming back at me
from from the city side like that is is
acting like a city
but
so think about it they think about it in
terms of your
your parts it's the best way to
understand if you want to help you
understand it you need to be able to try
to find the analogies
of your part right so you could say that
you have processes let's say in your
in your mind or in your experience so
you have you have you have certain
processes that manage different aspects
of your of your reality you have
processes that manage or express your
emotions you have processes that will
calculate you have different processes
and it's not it's not like you don't
even have to be able to fully identify
them let's say there could be some
malleability in that yeah but those
those you could say that those process
your
singular existence
your soul
your spirit
is is an image of those smaller
processes you could do it the same
like the manner in which the processes
unify a certain aspect of reality so
let's say you have a certain process
which unifies different things together
and kind of manifest then in the same
way you
the top part
do you do the same to all the all the
processes so so if to say for example
that one is the image of the other it's
just it's not a it's not super used it
could be useful i see not that it's not
as useful as you think maybe you know so
it's genuinely fractal i guess is yeah
it is so similar yeah yeah it's freckle
all the way down because those processes
will have processes and there's an
indefinite amount of sub levels where
each sub level will have the same
structure as the higher level so we but
then we
that scales up
that scales up too from the from the
unit from the person
into communions of persons
and so but you can also if you want to
understand at least let's say like how
the how the being of a city works you
can understand it
let's say if you've ever found yourself
as the leader of a team
you can experience the higher
consciousness of a city
when you're a leader you can actually
experience it because all of a sudden
you have a bigger body
but it's not you because obviously if it
was just you people wouldn't follow you
it's because you're the leader of the
team doing something in common but you
can nonetheless participate in that
experience where it's like you know
you're you're sitting at a table and
then people tell you their opinions and
then you decide and you say we're going
to do this and then all of a sudden all
the different agents align themselves in
front of what you've decided and now
they act as an extension of your body
well i guess and so then that kind of
brings the idea of authority to mind
because they do that
they do that if you have authority right
because if you don't and and maybe
that's like doing it in the name of
something so like in the name of
in the name of this end
we're going to do this so do we all want
to pursue this end and then that's like
just kind of
adjust kind of pattern right that's
exactly the way it works and so you can
understand it so for example if you want
to understand a society you could
understand let's say a medieval
structure of a society where they had
they had a almost like a caste system
because those that pray those that fight
those that work and they're embedded
into each other
that is that
let's say you do business but if you're
if when you do business you're not
serving a higher
goal
then at some point it's going to become
self-devouring and it's not going to
sustain reality
that's when you get you get parasitical
parasitic patterns
you get idolatry is a good way to
understand it so imagine someone in city
services becomes a little tyrant and
decides to do things for themselves and
so so they become corrupt does that mean
to be to be like to name
it's kind of like there's a self naming
in that right like you follow me
like why do we do this because me
like because of my name instead of like
in a higher name
yeah that's what idolatry is that's why
the idea that the gods required worship
like this whole thing that they're
talking about in lord of spirits the
idea that the gods took worship for
themselves and in doing that they
castrate the father right
they cut themselves away from the seed
of that which is above them and when
they do that then they open they open
the door for corruption underneath them
it's like they're basically opening the
door for revolution and breakdown
so when you so so you can see it like it
you can see it in a city when a city
becomes corrupt and then the people in
the city start to act on their own
accord
and they don't act towards the communion
of the city at the higher goal of it
then you get social breakdown and it
manifests itself all the way down that
the money doesn't get to the projects
the streets aren't fixed the building
start to fall apart the police doesn't
police properly everything starts to
fragment because
the different principalities aren't
aligned towards the towards the higher
uh higher identity
so so i guess this kind of connects to
the second thing
i wanted to talk about with with church
like
the the word like ecclesia uh kind of
brings this connotation of like
community
and so there's
um
so a city breaks down
if it's not structured according to the
right authority i guess i'm wondering
like what
how do mean you as members of our cities
uh
change that or like what kind of agency
do we have in that process and i think
that's connected to
to prayer or like even more well like
generally culture things like music
things like street art or like just the
ways the city
kind of manifests one of the ways
i thought about this idea of a city and
then just an electronic music producer i
really love
has has written music that kind of seems
to me to like capture the soul of london
and like there's
it's just when i was meditating on this
idea that you'd mention the city as a
being and then
so so
my point is is that as members we're
we seem to be kind of um
do i want to say co-creating or kind of
um
like are
the way in which we
use our logos or the way in which we
pray and ask different questions of the
city
kind of is connected to the fate of the
city
isn't it and
yeah what would you make um
what do you make of that and i guess
sorry it's a bit of a rambling one um
um
now maybe i'll just shut up
yeah but
so
so the first thing you need to
understand the first thing also you need
to understand is that the city itself
is not the top of the hierarchy
of being right and so it's like the city
will only be alive if it's ultimately
aligned towards higher goods besides
just the this besides just the city
itself it has to be it has to be
attached to god ultimately you could say
you know in order for
things to lay themselves out properly
and so of course
it's hard because things never
tend to not
rarely be completely aligned under god
you could say but so a way in which a
way in which for example let's say you
you're you're in a city and you see the
city uh fall apart
it's falling apart now the one of the
ways to stop the city from doing that is
to attach yourself to a higher good
so you can think of it like
so think of it so an easy way would be
something like an easy way to understand
it would be that if you're writing the
city
you say you're writing the city because
the pothole is falling so you're sending
a letter to the
to the to the the municipal garage or
whatever and then they're not doing it
so at some point you're going to write a
letter to your
counselor city councilor
right and then but then it's not
happening and then at some point you're
going to write a letter to right to the
mayor whatever you're going to escalate
the hierarchy in order to make to see
things happen and so you could
understand that that also embodiment is
part of that which is that
if you're watching the breakdown of the
city around you
like you embodying the ideal
of the city
will help to mend
things as they're breaking down
so you could think of it like um
right everybody's a jerk to everybody
else it's a big city nobody's talking to
anybody it's like i'm gonna be the
exception i'm going to
make cookies for my neighbor or whatever
it is you decide to do
to to restructure your immediate
surrounding
according to a higher good
um and the amount of transformation you
can
you can create is really surprising
actually
yeah you can be very surprised at how
much transformation you can bring about
by doing that um we tend to we tend to
neglect the
neglect the capacity for people because
what you you're sending out ripples and
you're actually creating new models
because one of the people model
themselves on each other that's how we
work right we and so if there are no
models around us then we we tend to
degenerate
now if we if someone just sets
themselves up as a model
people will start to imitate it
especially if it's a model that is that
is bringing about a a greater good or
they'll hate you
it could be either one
they could either model or they could
hate you and then
it'll still transform them even though
you
transform them even though they hate you
right
that's like one of the what's one of the
revelations of the christian mystery
let's say is that sometimes when you do
that they hate you and they kill you or
whatever they eject you but then it's
still it still does it it still does the
trick even though it's not it's not fun
for you
yeah yeah
so like it does the pattern of that you
said you know the self-eating idea like
that seems almost like logically
well
you use the word self-defeating so it's
like is there a way where that pattern
is kind of um
i don't know metaphysically broken and
that
the true authority kind of idea we were
talking about like um
well we'll come back yeah you can
imagine it like there are several ways
out of the out of the chaos one is to
restore to remember right i use those
terms a lot in my videos
remember remember that which binds us
remember that which connects us and so
in remembering you're reconnecting
yourself and you're
you know but the other way is also the
way down is works too
but it's just that it's it's not as fun
right it's like if things total if
everything breaks down and total chaos
uh rains then you know
whatever seed is there is going to grow
in that chaos
but it can be painful
right yeah
um yeah no thank thanks for thanks for
exploring that with me okay um
i guess
the the other kind of thing was um was
it it's a bit is it yeah it's a bit of a
different topic so it's like
um
how can i say so
i guess what i
learned personally this last year is the
the
how
my own
uh prayer it's like the the
how impotent my own prayer is or
something like that or like at least my
own efforts and my own self-reliance how
i guess in terms of
my spiritual life like
being
aimed in the wrong direction
sinning there's lots of ways in which
i'm aware of doing that myself and like
i want to stop doing that and repent and
turn and aim in a different direction
and i guess i've made
as earnest an effort as i can to do that
this year yeah
and it failed yeah
it was just like being that's the
meaning of humility i guess is like
being very brought low
in that kind of thing
and then
and so i guess the reason i'm mentioning
it is because one of the things that
really struck me in your work is this
kind of call to church and
and church as community or as
kind of something higher than just my
own self-reliance and i i just it
strikes me as intuitively true you're
saying that i'm just
personally figuring out
i guess what the ideal structure of
prayer is or like do others need to be
praying around me in the same direction
these kind of questions like
um
is me trying to ask the right questions
alone gonna be enough because it doesn't
seem to be it seems like
we all kind of need to pray together
kind of thing and
so i've seen that as a big theme in your
work um
so do you like do you think it's like
necessary
to join
community communities or higher bodies
to
fully
to live a spiritual life to like aim
properly and to repent of sin can we do
it on our own like do
what is the place of community etc
um
yeah but i i definitely think that it's
better
um
it's definitely better because you're
also inserting yourself into a hierarchy
like a functional hierarchy
the difficulty with a lot of spiritual
work let's say is that we often get
deluded
we we just
we um
we think we're acting towards our own
good but we're all we're actually just
imbibing our own passions we don't even
realize it and so it's good to have
people around you to be able to point
that out to you
um or be able to kind of
uh burst your bubble of the of illusion
so i think that that's definitely it's
better to be part of an actual community
um and for sure it's like a like the
church for example like a traditional
church what's what's great about that is
that you're also involved in uh in the
hierarchy of authority
and so right if your buddy like let's
say your buddy is uh
comes up to you and says you know what
you should lay off a sauce you drink too
much or whatever
you know i mean maybe like maybe it'll
have an effect on you or maybe not right
it's difficult because it's not like
they have an authority over you but they
don't they they're not allowed to tell
you what to do and so
putting yourself in a situation where
you have someone who's actually allowed
to tell you what to do
it can be sometimes be useful because
when someone tells you what to do
um
like this is like the secret that the
entire modern world hates
uh they don't realize it but when
someone tells you what to do
they are also inviting you especially if
they have authority over you they're
also inviting you to draw your capacity
to do it in them
because it's like you're you're you're
actually you're you're drawing your
attention you're drawing your capacity
to do whatever you need to do
in them and they also bear some
responsibility
on whether or not you succeed
right
yeah they do right they uh so imagine a
parent with a child right it's like a
parent tells the child what to do the
child doesn't do it the child is naughty
but the fact that the child doesn't do
it actually reflects on the parent and
so the parent actually has
has some responsibility for the fact
that the child doesn't do it and so in a
spiritual relationship with uh with a um
with a spiritual father with a priest
that's what's also what happens is that
they are when they tell you what to do
they are also somewhat making themselves
responsible for the consequence of that
to a certain extent not completely it's
yours but it's also theirs as well
um
and so
so that that's actually like if you've
ever experienced someone
let's say you're you're in a sports team
is a good way to experience it it's
actually pretty simple right it's like a
coach
tells you what to do
and it's like he could have said many
things but he says this this is the play
this is what we're going to do
and he's like it's going to work the
church or the team captain it's going to
work this is going to be our
our play and so you're like yeah all
right and so you draw in what that
person tells you to do the energy to do
it
and then you do it
and if it fails it's not just your fault
it's his fault too
yeah
he can call you out though he could call
you out and say i saw you didn't put all
your juice into the play like i saw you
kind of skimped out on us you didn't
totally put yourself into it there'll be
a negotiation between whose
responsibility is but it's not going to
just be yours so there's a there's an
advantage to community
uh which is that that's a great
advantage do you think that's a do you
think that's necessary and essential
like because it because yeah you
mentioned the modern age and it strikes
me that like
that's kind of the whole problem is like
our relationship to authority and our
like and maybe it's something to do with
adolescence and growing and like trying
to become
someone independent of our parents i
don't know but there's a kind of
modern
resistance to all authority and
it that seems to be connected to a whole
host of problems yeah but the thing is
the secret is that it's it's actually
not it's both it's
the the kind of obsession
with let's say um
removing authority like this kind of
obsession with like being your own man
and acting in authority and everything
is in isn't it funny that that way of
thinking came comes about at the same
time as the state is acquiring absolute
power over your life
that it's actually those extremes will
just
real traditional authority is more
fractal and is more organic and is this
kind of negotiation and discussion
between the levels whereas our world is
rock and roll rebel
you know rock and roll rebel taking
drugs doing whatever i want dude i'm
totally totally free and i can't build
like uh i can't put like a a porch on my
house without getting a permit from the
city and i have to do it with like so
many feet and so much thing and
everything and it's like
that's that's the modern world the
modern world
is those two extremes at the same time
it's like an extreme of of like
ultimate absolute power that completely
permeates your existence and at the same
time this kind of weird anarchist
anarchist rebellion like the internet is
a perfect example of that the internet
exemplifies that that extreme
in in the such a sublime way that it's
almost
you know
it's the promise of like doing of being
anything you want of saying anything you
went if you want metaverse you could be
whatever you want there's no limit you
could become you could be a lobster
a centaur if you want and in metaverse
there's no limit but
really interesting it's like they'll be
controlling every word you say at the
same time so it's like it's an
interesting extreme that the modern
world is
yeah which is i guess just authority
creeping back in right it's like the
authorities there
either way but it's like it's like an
extreme authority based on an extreme
freedom and it's not a normal
it's not a normal
negotiated fractal authority
because it's like
in in a normal world like think of a
parent and a child right like a normal
parent right so the parent says
do this right
and then
they have to be attentive to the child
even if they don't know they are
because i could say
i want you to do this like i want you to
clean your room
and it's like the child's like okay i'll
obey my parents i'll clean my room then
the parent could say i want you to clean
your room i want you to clean the house
i want you to paint the house i want you
and it's like just and then of a sudden
it's like the child will just not do it
it won't and it's the same child that
was willing to do the clean the room at
the outset
then they won't
and so it's like relationship normal
relationships between authority and
and uh people under authority is is a
constant like observing negotiation and
and and it's like and then the child
has to perceive that they get something
from
that relationship too
so there's like a fittedness that's
really interesting and that and that is
constraining excess
yeah
and is that connected to the encounter
of persons like oh like there's a
yeah is that because
of relationship that
i'm
fitting myself to
my parent or to my authority and trying
to come into the proper
relationship and yeah there is something
very like living or organic about that
and so you're saying that
i guess the internet or maybe technology
generally but let's say the internet is
not a living in that same
way it just tends towards extremes
it just tends towards extremes and the
extreme the ex it's the it's the extreme
talk
so think about think about in your
person right so it's like
man i want to be free from all these
authorities i want to be free i want to
be free it's like i want to be free to
do whatever i want
and then the guy starts drinking and
drinking or whatever and then becomes an
alcoholic and all of a sudden is a slave
to that god like an absolute slave and
they're all their reality now becomes
negotiated
for that one thing that has now enslaved
them so that's the that's the irony the
irony of of wanting to break down the
structures of
of normal structures of authority end up
creating tyrannical structures of
authority
that that will just completely control
um you it's actually in the in the
process itself it just happens it's not
uh yeah
i don't that makes sense
yeah
i mean
yeah it makes some sense i guess
i guess the
yeah i guess the main thing i
the way i'm thinking about it is like it
it
it's just it's
it's this submission thing because like
in the sports thing you mentioned or
like the military might be another good
example there's a
military particularly there's this
emphasis on like submission like it's
like you can't actually be a part of the
body
without submission right like if you're
not submitting to the your local
authority and you're not in right
relation as you're saying you're like
out of the body like it cannot kind of
exist if that's the case
yeah you have to submit and in the
military especially like in a normal
kind of military world there'll be a
fittedness of course you'll be
fittedness
because it's like the if the commander
can tell you okay now run 10k it's like
that's something but he's not going to
say run 100k
yeah like if he says that
he's just his
his troop is going to is going to
disband it's going to cease to exist
or they're going to die
why do you think that is he's just
asking too much of them yeah it's just
not fit it's just not fitted
but you could get them to run 100 100k
but you would need a concentration camp
where the people are prisoners and now
you say you do that or i kill you
and then they will run 100k
right that's what i mean it's like it's
like
that
there's a
let's say that the extremes let's say
it's those extremes that that show break
down the pattern
it's like you're saying there's a kind
of um
organic or intrinsic justice
to the authority like if i'm if someone
is submitted to me there's almost like
an inherent
just this is probably the word i want to
use to to the demands i can actually
make
on those below
i guess for practical reasons as well
uh yeah it's just inevitable like it
it's it's just really reality playing
itself out if you're not attentive to
the needs of so you could say so for
example like you could say that the
french revolution is
is a
was a result of a breakdown in the
normal relationship of authority that
should exist in in a society and so it's
like i cannot i can disagree with the
peasants killing the king but i can
understand it
i can understand why as the as let's say
the the aristocracy separated itself
from its people and then stopped
actually engaging in just wanted to get
taxes from their land but weren't there
like making sure the kids were going to
school you know making sure his his
serps were were receiving medical
treatment or whatever it is that a lord
should do
then at some point
it doesn't hold like it that that that
system doesn't hold and it's like that
for all normal authority systems
i mean something that people today have
such difficulty understanding but
it's like the idea for example that like
jordan peterson jokes about that joke
but you mentioned that a lot like the
idea that like women have been oppressed
for 10 000 years by men and that like
the the characteristic of of
relationship between men and women has
been like masculine dominance and
oppression it's just it's just absolute
[ __ ] like it could never it could
never
be sustainable
like there would always have to be a
negotiation between
between between the the relationship
between the man and the woman and
sometimes it might go a little too much
on one side sometimes it might go a
little too too little on the other side
but you can't really
you can't
hold it in the extreme for a long time
unless you supplement it with technology
if you supplement it with technology
then you can go really far in one
direction or the other
so you can create you can create i think
that's something it seems intuitively it
feels like that's connected to
use the word organic
it it just feels like the a computer's
not organic
and that there's something there like
there's
something like quantitative and
logarithmic or algebraic or you know
about that whole system
that isn't like my relationship to my
mother or my boss or the different human
persons i encounter
yeah but it's it's extension of power
it's always an extension of human power
and so so let's say in a normal like in
a normal relationship let's say in a
normal uh
in a normal power relationship
right there's a leader and there's
someone following them so the leader
asks something of the person following
them
and that person
kind of follows maybe they use a little
bit of coercion at some point there's a
limit
at some points like at some point it's
just going to break
but if i have a gun
i have way more power
over you to make you do whatever the
hell i want
i say right if i have a if i have a
military
then i can make then i can push that
further if i have a system of of of uh
spying if i have a system of
of uh controlling your of turning off
your bank account if i have power if i
have material power then i can go
further in the extreme
uh and the same even for
like uh in terms of the anarchy it's
like
anarchy is only possible in a very
controlled
you know a system that has a lot of
resources because in a normal system
without a lot of power it doesn't hold
it just you die you just die really fast
it's like i want nothing to do with
these people i don't want to participate
in their society you know i'm a rebel
yeah okay
let's see how long you survived my
friend you know it's like but we only do
that we can only do be that way in a
world that is so completely padded with
with a kind of technocratic society that
we don't we don't see it like it's yeah
so all of these things end up being
co-related
i see
i guess yeah
the final i guess to come towards
wrapping up it would be like
the
i'm curious about the relationship
between um like why don't we accept
authority like i think there's a kind of
i guess one of my intuitions was around
the adolescent kind of rebellion idea
but
also like
i think there's a connection between
the more i've learned about christianity
and kind of reflected on my own life
like
humility or being brought low
and
and submission
um
yeah i just i wonder what you think
about why we don't accept authority and
what how we might
how
viewers or how how we might look
to
come into a proper relationship
i mean the best way is to understand i
think the best way for us to understand
is that it's inevitable right that
authority is inevitable that we actually
we we follow authority all the time you
know every time you stop at a stop sign
every time you
drive on the right side of the road
you're obeying authority we obey
authority all the time and so i think
that at least becoming aware of that
can help us understand the inevitability
of this like like i said a lot of people
who think that they're being rebels and
and as they're deluded they think they
are and they they they maybe act that
way on some vectors but they are not
like it's
it's a it's a it's a little bit of an
illusion which is based on this padding
that we talked about so i think that
that's
probably a good idea is to just realize
that it's inevitable and then also
understand the negotiation part or
understand that
authority isn't always just top down
it's just very rarely so especially in
normal authority relationships because i
need to a lot i need to
follow your command for it to be
authority right then yeah and i need to
follow it but i also need to
um how can i say this it's like i need
to get something from authority
there's absolutely if i don't get
something from authority
the only way you will be able to
uh let's say enforce your authority will
be through brute force
total brute force now and brute force is
is is exhausting
it's tiring
yeah it takes your energy it takes up
energy and so it's it's a it's a simple
it's like it's it's a kind of a simple
system and you can see it like um
you can see it like it's in modern
classrooms like modern classrooms are
great because the teacher doesn't have
real authority like doesn't have normal
authority and
it's recognized that in a way
the children the the teacher isn't an
authority figure right and that's in the
culture so the kids they they they'll
flip between
being screamed at by like a hysterical
uh person
to doing whatever they want and not
listening to what the teacher says and
it's like
there isn't
because they don't understand authority
they can't they don't
even the teacher doesn't understand
authority because the teacher is part of
this weird weird world where they they
also think that some they're teachers
but they think authority is bad you know
it's like you know that's that's not
going to work um so they end up like
going between extremes but normally what
you would have is that the
right the students know that if they
obey authority things are going to go
better for them and for everybody else
and if it doesn't then at some point
it's also might they might not continue
to
to obey
like it's just gonna it's gonna break
down
people will go
somewhere else
yeah i it's it's interesting thinking
about my experience at school because i
agree i think they were they were on one
extreme teachers who
abdicated authority entirely but also
just tyrants who
i don't know tyrants but like
uh teachers who would go around say like
you know tuck your [ __ ] like tuck your
shirt in do your tie up like you know
keep that aesthetic proper
and you know that teacher was obviously
perceived as a bit of a
bad like just annoyance or tyrant in our
school you know always
kind of known for that
but then i guess it relates to
i don't know i think i want to say
justice like whether the authority is
justified like do i understand like why
should i dug my shirt in yeah and what
like why and i think that's kind of
what you're pointing at there with this
with the way in which schools aren't
kind of like connected to uh
so think of your best teachers like
think of your best teachers usually most
people like maybe i'm wrong but most
people if you ask them who their best
teachers were they usually identify
something like
a teacher was who was very strict but
very involved
like a teacher that was quite strict the
way that they ran their classroom was
actually quite demanding in terms of
what they asked of the students but were
completely dedicated
and would give you the time would take
the time to help you understand if you
were wanting to understand they would
write comments in your papers they would
they would you know like
they would they would care and so it's
like
you're strict but you care so
that's like that's a really amazing
thing you know and so it's like we tend
to not be able to realize that that
exists we tend to think if someone's
strict it's because they're tyrants and
they don't care
and because and if someone is is just
lets things go then it's because they
care but they're not strict it's like no
actually those two things together are
usually what make a pretty good teacher
totally
oh thanks for that jennifer therefore
that yeah that particular note there is
like might be a nice place to end it i
think that's that's a really um
yeah like the the merciful and the just
the strict the love and and the
and the discipline as well
um
yeah and i love i love the stuff about
fittedness and relationship in authority
because i've never
necessarily made that connection before
um
i thought i'm happy that it was it was
useful yeah
good conversation i enjoyed it for sure
cool let me see
as you know the symbolic world is not
just a bunch of videos on youtube we are
also a podcast which you can find on
your uh usual podcast platform but we
also have a website with a blog and
several very interesting articles by
very intelligent people that have been
thinking about symbolism on all kinds of
subjects we also have a clips channel a
facebook group you know there's a whole
lot of ways that you can get more
involved in the exploration and the
discussion of symbolism don't forget
that my brother matsuya wrote a book
called the language of creation which is
a very powerful synthesis of a lot of
the ideas that explore and so please go
ahead and explore this world you can
also participate by you know buying
things that i've designed t-shirts with
different designs on them and you can
also support this podcast and these
videos through paypal or through patreon
everybody who supports me has access to
an extra video a month and there are
also all kinds of other goodies and
tiers that you can get involved with so
everybody thank you again and thank you
for your support